teachers in florida are taking legal
action to try to stop school openings
amid the pandemic the state of florida
has now topped
360 thousand total cases since the
crisis began
but governor ron desantis is still
insisting on in-person classes
our lead national correspondent david
begno is in miami beach david good
morning quite the face-off here what's
really going on
so tony look the governor is standing
his ground saying the schools have to
reopen for in-person classes
he's almost being as strong about that
as he has about mass mandates
not issuing a statewide mass mandate
order in fact florida is the only state
along the gulf coast that doesn't have
some kind of order statewide
telling people to wear masks that kind
of conviction from the governor
is leading to public outbursts of
criticism watch this
if you had been infected then you
yet again florida's governor was heckled
yesterday at a public event
this time he was pleading for
convalescent plasma donations
donate your plasma it's very very
important you can make a difference in
people's
health and in their lives the need is
critical jeff gerson
is on a ventilator fighting for his life
six days ago doctors told his wife dulce
he could benefit from a plasma
transfusion but that donor blood wasn't
readily available
when you're told that they are um
eligible for plasma or that plasma may
help them
this is not the time to have to plea for
someone
who has the potential to donate to do so
um we have minutes hours
maybe a day to get that medicine to our
family members
and time is crucial so in my husband's
case it's
a little too late but i'm hoping
somebody doesn't have to go through this
page
meanwhile the florida education
association is taking aim at the
governor with a lawsuit
looking to halt his plan to reopen
schools next month
carla hernandez matz teaches middle
school in miami-dade county
it is ludicrous to think that now
when the fire is even hotter when the
when the buildings are really burning
um that we would take our children out
of these protective bubbles that we've
created
you know we can mitigate learning losses
but the reality is that we cannot
mitigate loss of life
the florida education foundation is the
largest teachers union in the state
their lawsuit is believed to be the
first of its kind in the united states
during this pandemic
and it essentially accuses the governor
of violating his constitutional
mandate to keep schools safe and secure
gail one more thing before we go
if you are a coronavirus survivor and
you can donate that plasma
go to oneblood.org that's oneblood.org
it will save lives
yes yes yes that's very important
information thank you david